ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen es
sind zwei Videos die es in sich haben
und das auf zum Teil erschreckende Art
und Weise der Chef der Söldnertruppe
Wagner prigoshien hat auf telegram
einerseits offenbar vor Leichen seiner
Söldner posiert und der russischen
Militärführung schwere Versäumnisse
vorgeworfen bis hin zu persönlichen
Beleidigungen dazu gleich mehr bei uns
im Stream zum anderen hat er den Rückzug
der Wagner Truppen zum 10 Mai
angekündigt aus bachmut wenn weiter
nicht ausreichend Munition kommt sonst
Ruhe seinen Kämpfern ein Zitat sinnloser
Tod
wir fragen ob das Anzeichen dafür sind
dass Putins Front zusammenbricht wir
sprechen über beide Videos und deren
Bedeutung mit Margarete klein sie ist
Russland Expertin von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und gleich zu
Beginn mit Nato-General ade Egon Rams
schön guten Abend
ja schön dass Sie wieder bei uns sind
heran sollte ihn seine Drohung wahr
machen und tatsächlich am 10 Mai seine
Söldner Truppen aus bachmut abziehen
welche militärischen Folgen hätte das
und zunächst mal die Aussage er hat sich
ja bereits vier oder fünf mal geäußert
gegenüber der Militärführung in Russland
und hat seinen Missfallen zum Ausdruck
gebracht es ist jetzt das erste Mal dass
er diesen Rückzug terminiert hat auf den
10 Mai und man darf nicht vergessen dass
sowohl die Einnahme von wulleda als auch
die Einnahme oder jetzt die weitgehende
Einnahme von bachmut überwiegend einen
eine Leistung oder ein Verdienst seiner
Söldnertruppe ist und nicht der
regulären russischen Streitkräfte das
heißt wenn er sich dort zurückzieht ist
bachmut vermutlich in relativ kurzer
Zeit wieder komplett in den Händen der
Ukraine darauf werden wir gleich noch
ein Gedanke für diese erste Antwort wie
immer die Aufforderung an euch uns eure
Fragen und Kommentare zu schicken über
Social Media oder per Mail heraus der
Kampf um bachmut dauert bereits seit
Anfang August welche Bedeutung hat
dieser Ort eigentlich ist sie mehr
militärisch oder inzwischen eher
symbolisch
also zu Anfang war es eine strategische
Bedeutung weil die Ukrainer diesen Ort
und vor allen Dingen auch die Wege in
diesen Ort von Nordwesten bzw Westen
benötigten um auch Nachschub in diesen
Raum zu bringen für die ukrainischen
Truppen
das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr so
ausschlaggebend so dass ich davon
ausgehe dass es im Augenblick um die
moralische und psychologische Wirkung
geht diesen Ort weiter zu verteidigen
wenn auch Teile bereits durch die Wagner
Truppe entsprechende erobert worden sind
da geht es um die Moral der Soldaten
aber auch die das entsprechende Signal
an die ukrainische Bevölkerung die
Ukraine übrigens sieht keine Anzeichen
für einen baldigen wagnerabzug aus
bachmut und auch nicht für einen akuten
Munitionsmangel sie sehen in der
frigoschen Ankündigung lediglich den
Versuch vom eigenen Versagen abzulenken
da das Ziel bachmut bis zum 9 mai zu
erobern außer Reichweite gerate was
sagen sie dazu
9 mai ist in Russland ein wichtiger Tag
obwohl mittlerweile schon viele
russische Städten die sogenannten
siegesparaden abgesagt haben von daher
spielt der 9 mai sagt dass man in der
Wahrnehmung der Russen eine relativ
große Bedeutung vor allen Dingen auch
der Regierung eine große Bedeutung von
daher ist es nicht auszuschließen dass
auf diese Art und Weise Druck ausüben
will auf der anderen Seite kann er als
Kommandeur der Gruppe Wagner nicht
hinnehmen dass er ständig in diesem Ort
riesengroße Verluste hat die ja von den
Amerikanern insgesamt eingeschätzt
werden mit nahezu 20.000 Soldaten und
seine Verluste oder die Verluste werden
überwiegend von der Gruppe Wagner
getragen es wäre sprechen in wenigen
Minuten weiter wollen uns aber vorher
noch eine politische Analyse dieser
Situation um pregorien einholen daher
nun zunächst der Bericht von meinem
Kollegen Pablo silalai
nur wenige Stunden vor der Ankündigung
seine Truppe aus bachmut abziehen zu
wollen veröffentlicht privat schien auf
Telegramm dieses Video der Wagner Chef
posiert darin vor mehreren Leichen hier
sind die Männer von Wagner die heute
gestorben sind sogar ihr Blut ist noch
warm ruft er
und wird persönlich
spricht Russlands Verteidigungsminister
Schall GU und dessen Generalstabschef
gerasimov direkt an
wirft ihnen vor untätig herumzusetzen
kurz nach bekannt werden des Videos
werden diese Bilder öffentlich Schal
Gruber einem Truppenbesuch in Russland
südliche Militärbezirk dabei soll er
auch Ausrüstung inspiziert haben und
angewiesen haben die Versorgung der
Soldaten mit allen notwendigen Waffen
sicherstellen seit Monaten ist die Stadt
bachmut im Osten der Ukraine schwer
umkämpft nach eigenen Angaben
kontrolliert die wagnertruppe inzwischen
80% der Stadt sollte pregorien den
angedrohten Rückzug wirklich wahr machen
würde das zu einem symbolischen
Zeitpunkt geschehen nur einen Tag
nachdem Russland am 9 mai den Jahres Tag
des Siegs über das
nationalsozialistische Deutschland
feiert die Proben für die große
Militärparade sind schon in vollem Gange
und wir vertiefen das Thema mit
Margarete klein Osteuropa und Russland
Expertin von der Stiftung Wissenschaft
und Politik in Berlin einen schönen
guten Abend hallo
vor kleinen neben den Beschimpfungen
Richtung Verteidigungsminister und
generalstaatschef hat Wagner Chef
prigoschin also auch den Rückzug zum 10
Mai angekündigt falls keine Munition für
seine Leute komme wie ist diese
Ankündigung zu bewerten es ist ja auch
nicht die erste dieser Art
es ist nicht die erste und neues auch
nicht die Kritik am
Verteidigungsminister und einem
generalstaatschef neu ist wirklich
dieser massiv beleidigende persönliche
Ton plus vor allem dass er diese Toten
Söldner zeigt und das unterminiert ja
eigentlich diese Erzählung von Putin
dass es sich bloß um die
spezialoperation handelt mit relativ
geringen Verlusten und indem er eben
diese abzugsdrohung Macht übt da
massiven Druck auf um eben seinen
Forderungen entgegenzukommen nach einer
besseren Ausstattung seiner Truppen und
nach einer Stärkung eigentlich auch
seiner Truppen im Vergleich zum
Verteidigungsministerium das sozusagen
spielt schon rein in die Antwort denke
ich auf die Frage die wir bekommen haben
über Youtube wie ernst muss die Figur
priorchin genommen werden kann er den
Kreml noch ernsthafte Schwierigkeiten
machen
also es ist so dass in der Debatte oft
politisch Bedeutung von pregorien
überschätzt wird als eine Art von
möglichen Nachfolger von Putin er ist
ein Unternehmer und ein gewaltaktor mit
einem sehr breiten Portfolio an Sachen
die er anbietet und er ist ein Profiteur
dieses Kriegers denn er kann mit seiner
Söldnertruppe Geld und Einfluss
generieren und den möchte eben
abschützen zugleich ist es so dass er ja
nicht in diesen herrschenden Eliten fest
integriert ist denn ersten Outsider er
kommt nicht aus dem Geheimdienst sondern
eher kommt eigentlich er beim Gefängnis
und da ist dann im klassischer
Unternehmer geworden also von dem her
hat er nicht diese Verankerung und was
macht er in so einer Situation er
schafft so eine Art ideologische
Unterfütterung für sich er spricht davon
dass in Russland ein tiefer Staat
herrsche bestärkt von den dekadenten
Eliten damit meinte die herrschende
Elite die sich eigentlich lieber
verweislich ihren Vergnügungen hingeht
während er der Leiter einer sogenannten
Volksarmee mehr oder weniger sei die
eigentlich die Arbeit macht Russland
wieder groß zu machen und das ist
tatsächlich eine politische Verbrennung
die zeigt dass er politische Dinge nutzt
um eigentlich sein Geschäft abzusichern
und das ist auch vermutlich die
Intention die dahinter steckt warum er
das ganze überhaupt so in die
Öffentlichkeit transportiert das fragt
uns nämlich schon die Tee warum macht er
das
er möchte maximale Aufmerksamkeit das
ist zum einen Branding seine Marke
Wagner hat mittlerweile schon fast
Kultstatus in manchen Bereichen es gibt
eine Jugendorganisation er rekrutiert
zunehmend in Sportclubs und er hat ja
ein ganzes Portfolio an Geschäften das
ja auch hat also das ist Branding seiner
Marke und sogleich schafft er eben doch
diese Aufmerksamkeit auch den Druck um
die Unterstützung der Armee zu bekommen
denn das muss man auch sehr klar sagen
seine sollten naturtruppe könnte nicht
agieren wenn es nicht die Unterstützung
gäbe bei der Ausrüstung bei der
Ausstattung und bei trainingsgelenten
durch das Verteidigungsministerium ja
interessant auch eben die Rolle des
Kreml in diesem Zusammenhang also
Präsident Putin verhält sich ja
auffallen zurückhaltend angesichts
dieser doch sehr harten Kritik von
gregorien erhält also keine erkennbar
schützende Hand vor seine Militärführung
warum tut Putin das nicht
also zum einen hat frigoshi nicht diese
rote Linie überschritten die es dem
Kreml unmöglich machen würde mit ihm
zusammen zu arbeiten das wäre wenn ja
Putin direkt kritisieren würde ja nur
den Verteidigungsminister und
Generalstabschef kritisiert dann ist es
sicherlich auch so dass Putin über die
Erfolge der russischen Armee nicht
glücklich ist und zugleich braucht er
auch die Söldner um in eben gerade
personell verlustreiche Kämpfe kämpfen
zu können und zugleich muss man aber
auch sagen erhält ja auch keine wirklich
schützende Hand oder er oder der
kritisiert ja eigentlich auch nicht die
Militärführung offen sondern er lässt
diesen Konflikt mehr oder weniger laufen
und das ist etwas was wir von Putin
schon in vielerlei Hinsicht gesehen
haben dass er mehr oder weniger diese
Konflikte laufen lässt solange sie nicht
eine Qualität erreichen die Ihnen
persönlich angehen und deswegen ist es
eigentlich nichts ungewöhnliches
aber wenn er jetzt tatsächlich diese
Ankündigung wahr machen sollte und er
würde zum 10 Mai die Truppen
zurückziehen was würde das bedeuten
politisch auch für Putin
politisch wird es bedeuten dass dieser
Machtkampf der ja um die Verteilung
dieser großen Mittel geht im
Militärbudget dass der von Putin nicht
mehr kontrolliert werden kann wenn
tatsächlich der wagnerchef diese
Ankündigung wahr macht dann zeigt er
dass er sich nicht mehr einordnen lässt
in die Macht vertikale von Putin in der
durchaus bis jetzt immer noch drinnen
Ware und das wäre ein klares Zeichen der
Schwäche von Putin
verstehe Sven Odendahl fragt uns wohin
könnten die Wagner Söldner sich denn
zurückziehen nach Russland oder andere
Standorte der russischen einflussfähre
wäre ja sicherlich nicht möglich weil
sie Angst haben müssten standrechtlich
erschossen zu werden oder einen
Fenstersturz zu riskieren
also wenn sie sich tatsächlich
zurückziehen ohne Putins
Zugeständnis und es gibt ja noch eine
andere Interpretation die sagt das ist
letztendlich ein Fake um die Ukraine in
die Falle von bachmut zu locken sehe ich
weniger weil die persönlichen
Beleidigungen unter Druck den
triggerchen jetzt gemacht haben sind so
hoch dass dieses taktische Element
glaube ich nicht stimmt aber tatsächlich
wenn sie sich nicht mehr disziplinieren
ließen dann könnt ihr zumindest die
Führung von Wagner eigentlich nicht mehr
in Russland so weiter bestehen denn die
politische Führung um Putin hätte
weiterhin
disziplinierungsmöglichkeiten es ist ja
so dass diese Gruppierung eigentlich
illegal ist in Russland und so könnte
man relativ leicht dagegen vorgehen
Wagner Personal könnte dann eben
möglicherweise auch in die anderen
Standorte sich zurückziehen gerade in
afrikanischen Staaten wo eben Wagner
sehr aktiv auch ist von Mali über
Zentralafrikanische Republik bisschen
nach so dann vielleicht noch mal
abschließen die die Frage es wird ja
auch viel spekuliert über die
Durchhaltefähigkeit bei der
Kriegsparteien auch gerade auf auf
russische Seite deuten diese Vorgänge
jetzt eventuell auch darauf finden also
das beklagen von fehlender Munition das
Russland eine längeren Kriegsverlauf
doch nicht so ohne weiteres durchhalten
könnte eventuell
also wir sehen davon Anfang an dass die
personellen Verluste sehr sehr hoch sind
und dass die sogenannte stille
Mobilisierung also wo man versucht über
Anreize Leute zu mobilisieren nicht
wirklich funktioniert sondern hier muss
man Zwang anwenden und auch die
materiellen Verluste sind relativ hoch
vieles wird davon abhängen wie diese
ukrainische gegen Offensive dann
ausgeführt wird wie stark die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte sind personell
ausgerüstet aber eben auch in der
Ausbildung und in der Fähigkeit komplexe
Operationen durchzuführen das sind
eigentlich diese zwei Pfeiler also die
die Schwäche der russischen Armee und
zugleich die die Stärke der ukrainischen
und das wird man dann sehen politisch
ist es aber so dass die russische
Führung sich auf einen sehr langen Krieg
einstellt dafür spricht alles was man
bisher eigentlich hört von diesen nicht
abgehen von den Maximalforderungen vom
einschwören auf einen defacto fast
irgendwo heiligen Krieg dass man nicht
gegen die Ukraine kämpft sondern
eigentlich gegen den großen Westen und
vor allem gegen die USA also polit isch
sehen wir da noch keine abgeben vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzungen Margarete
klein war das von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik danke sehr und
einen schönen Abend
danke Ihnen auch Dankeschön und damit
kommen wir noch mal zurück zu unserem
militär-experten dem Nato-General ade
Egon Rams Herr Rams willkommen zurück
bei uns da sehe ich sie wunderbar wir
haben gerade über Russlands
Durchhaltefähigkeit gesprochen wie
schätzen sie denn die Kräfteverhältnisse
ein kann der Kreml einen womöglich noch
jahrelang dauernden Krieg tatsächlich
führen
also wenn der Kreml seine Wirtschaft
umstellt auf Kriegswirtschaft hat er
sicherlich genügend Kapazitäten auch im
sibirischen Raum um die entsprechende
Mengen an Munition auch neue Waffen und
dergleichen zu produzieren aber das
scheint bisher noch nicht erfolgt zu
sein wenn man Zahlen nimmt über den
Munitionsverbrauch etwas aus dem letzten
Jahr August September und die mit den
heutigen vergleicht dann ist sage ich
mal der Verbraucher Munition gerade
Atelier Munition bei der russischen
Seite doch deutlich gesunken das heißt
die Vorräte dort sind nicht
unerschöpflicht und bei Großgeräten
stellt man fest dass immer mehr
ältere Panzertypen auf dem Gefechtsfeld
auftauchen und von daher da
offensichtlich auch die Reserven nicht
so groß sind wie sie möglicherweise von
anderen Leuten entsprechend eingeschätzt
worden sind aber mit Blick auf die
Situation Ukraine Russland im Vergleich
hat Russland sicherlich das größere
Stehvermögen und das Stehvermögen der
Ukraine muss gewährleistet werden durch
die entsprechende Versorgung mit
Munition mit Großgerät mit Waffen vom
Besten her
ja wir haben einen Kommentar anonymer
Weise die oder besser eigentlich eine
Frage ist bachmut nicht unwichtig wenn
die Ukraine an anderer Stelle die Front
durchbricht also noch mal die Bedeutung
nach bachmut ist das denn jetzt nicht
vielleicht sozusagen der Fokus auf einen
Ort gelegt wenn gleich sozusagen auch an
anderer Stelle auch gekämpft wird
also ich hatte ja vorhin bereits gesagt
dass neben der ursprünglichen
strategischen Bedeutung bachmut jetzt
zur Zeit eine moralische und für die
Kampfhandlung ich sag mal psychisch
wichtige Bedeutung hat bei der Aussage
bleibe ich ich kann im Augenblick noch
nicht erkennen ob ein möglicher Angriff
der Ukraine die bekannte gegen Offensive
möglicherweise in eine andere Richtung
zielt das könnte beispielsweise runter
nach Süden seinen richtigen molitopol
also in der Oblast saporisia von daher
wäre das eine weitere Variante wenn aber
die Ukraine dort tatsächlich in diesen
Raum angreifen sollte dann würde das
bedeuten dass auch von der russischen
Seite her Kräfte umgruppiert werden
müssen und damit möglicherweise auch der
Raum bachmut nicht mehr so nachhaltig
angegangen werden kann wie das in den
letzten fünf oder sechs Monaten passiert
ist da kann ich gerade ein Haken denn
heute Nachmittag gab es diese Meldung
russland hat also die Teile Evakuierung
von Gebieten nahe der Südfront in der
Ukraine angeordnet Familien mit Kindern
und älteren Menschen sollten
vorübergehend wie Sie es aus von
Russland gehaltenen frontgebieten in der
Region saporicia diese gerade genannt
haben gebracht werden weil der Beschuss
von ukrainischer Seite zugenommen habe
18 Dörfer und Städte seien von der
Maßnahme betroffen dass erinnert ja ein
wenig an das russische Vorgehen in
Person letztes Jahr im November auch da
gab es damals einen Rückzug der
allerdings dann auch innenpolitisch in
Russland stark kritisiert wurde aber
auch diese Meldung jetzt scheint ja die
Zweifel an Russland Stärke im Süden
zumindest zu bestätigen
also ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass
die Ukraine ja damals im Raum Person
sehr erfolgreich mit weitreichende
Artillerie gewirkt haben und auf diese
Art und Weise auch ein Großteil des
Nachschubs der Russen abgeschnitten
haben so dass die Russen im Prinzip dann
das nördliche
Opfer räumen mussten eine ähnliche
Situation allerdings nicht vom Gelände
ja so vorteilhaft könnte sich mit Blick
auf militopol und Richtung Süden
ebenfalls entwickeln und offensichtlich
nehmen die Ukrainer jetzt wieder tiefer
liegende Bereiche von den Grenzlinien
aus in unter Feuer einfach auch wieder
um den gleichen Effekt zu erzielen
nämlich die vorne eingesetzten
russischen Truppen von Nachschub und
Versorgung abzuschneiden dafür sprechen
auch die beiden Unglücke mit den Zügen
wo die Gleise gesprengt worden sind
dafür sprechen auch die Angriffe auf die
treibstofflage die Stadt gefunden haben
von daher dürfte die Methodik und die
Art des Angriffs die Angriff
Vorbereitung wenn ich das mal so sagen
darf
von Seiten der Ukrainer dem ähneln was
damals in der oblastkason gemacht worden
ist das geht jetzt schon in den Bereich
Frühjahrsoffensive kommen wir gleich
auch noch mal kurz darauf zu sprechen
vorher noch die Frage von Matthias Koch
an sie kann es sein dass Putin viele
Ressourcen für die Creme zurückhält für
die Krim wohlgemerkt und diese nicht
unnötig für bachmut oder den Don Bass zu
opfern
das ist durchaus möglich die Krim spielt
für Putin eine symbolische Rolle in
symbolisch wichtige Rolle was in
gewisser Weise auch nachvollziehbar ist
die Lektion damals der Krim wurde ja
durch Russland mit den berühmten kleinen
grünen Männchen Betrieben seitdem
befindet sich die krimin im Besitz von
Russland er hat die Brücke von herrscht
die ja teilweise wieder zerstört worden
ist bauen lassen auf diese Art und Weise
die Versorgung der Krim sicherzustellen
von daher spielt das sicherlich auch für
Putin auch für Russland eine symbolische
Rolle die Krim zu halten und da
möglicherweise auch zusätzliche Kräfte
zusammenzuziehen aber ich muss in dem
Zusammenhang dann darauf hinweisen dass
wenn die Landbrücke zur Krim tatsächlich
verloren gehen sollte es für die Russen
schwierig wird auch über das schwarze
mehr mit entsprechender sehversorgung
und dergleichen mehr die Truppen dort
entsprechend zu versorgen so dass sie in
der Lage sind auch über einen längeren
Zeitraum Kampfhandlungen zu
durchzuhalten das gleich dann so ein
bisschen der Situation haben in der in
der Oblast Personen das könnte dann
ähnliche Entwicklung nehmen ja
interessanter Aspekt sie hatten es
vorhin schon angesprochen es wird viel
über die ja wahrscheinlich bevorstehende
ich nenne es mal so Frühjahrsoffensive
der Ukraine spekuliert oder hat die in
ihren Augen schon begonnen es gab ja sie
haben es angesprochen schon
Drohnenangriffe offenbar auf
Treibstofflager und auch andere
Infrastruktur also ist die schon im
Gange
also ich würde das bestenfalls als
Vorbereitung für diese gegen Offensive
wurde für die Offensive sehen die
offensivart in meinen Augen noch nicht
begonnen aber ich ziehe auch da noch mal
eine parallele einmal Richtung chakiff
im vergangenen Jahr und Richtung
Personen vergangenen Jahr in beiden
Bereichen ist lange über die gegen
Offensive der Ukrainer gesprochen worden
bevor sie dann tatsächlich mit
entsprechenden Gelände gewinnen sowohl
oben im Nordosten als auch unten im
Süden wirklich Raum gegriffen hat und
dann den Ukrainern tatsächlich Erfolge
gelungen sind die dann auch für uns alle
sichtbar auf der Karte gewesen sind das
ist einfach eine ganz einfache Tatsache
und eine Entwicklung könnte wenn der
Angriff das tatsächlich nach Süden mit
Schwerpunkt geführt wird könnte sich
dort auch in gleicher Art und Weise
ergeben
wo in etwa die ukrainische Offensive
sein könnte hat denn die Ukraine dafür
inzwischen auch genug schwere Waffen
auch genug ausgebildete Truppen ist sie
also militärisch in der Lage diese
Offensive auszuführen
also die Zahlen sind die Tage genannt
worden vom Nato-Generalsekretär der von
230 Kampfpanzern und von weiteren 1550
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen sprach die im
Prinzip aus dem Westen geliefert worden
sind die Ausbildung der Soldaten für die
bisher gelieferten
Kampffahrzeuge Kampfpanzer und Fahrzeuge
ist abgeschlossen wobei man die Zahl
1550 bitte nicht überbewerten sollte
denn dabei handelt es sich um alle Arten
von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen wie
Schützenpanzer
Panzer die dazu dienen Material oder
Personal zu transportieren das heißt das
sind nur relativ wenige Kampffahrzeuge
dabei die ich mal neben den 230
Kampfpanzern in der Größenordnung
vielleicht von 4 bis 500 einordnen
verstehe
eine Frage erreicht uns von QR DNK
Interesse sollten die sollten er fragt
noch mal nach Mut wirklich abziehen wie
wahrscheinlich wird dann die
militärische Eskalation also er meinte
mit Schwere der Waffen auch durch die
russische Regierung selbst denn die
würde ja voraussichtlich an die Stelle
der Wagner treten
also man müsste wenn die Wagner syltner
abziehen müsste man diese ersetzen
entweder durch ein anderes ziviles
hilfskurs gibt ja noch eins Patriot
heißt das wird von der Firma Gasprom
finanziert die dort auch jetzt bereits
zum Flankenschutz der Wagner sollten
eingesetzt sind ähnlich wie auch
russische reguläre Streitkräfte bis hin
zu Luft Landetruppen für diesen Schutz
dort sich befinden aber es würde
bedeuten dass die wagnergruppe im
Prinzip durch reguläre Streitkräfte
ersetzt werden müsste und das würde
möglicherweise die Fähigkeiten der
Russen in diesem Bereich durchaus
überschreiten dass die eine Anmerkung
und die zweite die ich dazu habe wir
alle wissen noch aus der aus dem
vergangenen Sommer das um oder Herbst
das obwohl ihr da gekämpft worden ist
mit einer ähnlichen langen nicht so
lange wie bachmut dauert aber auch
bachmut jetzt mit seinen fünf bis sechs
Monaten ist ja nun auch eine sehr lange
Kampfhandlung und eine sehr intensive
Kampfhandlung und man muss schlicht und
einfach feststellen dass offensichtlich
die regulieren Truppen die Erfolge die
die
Gruppe Wagner zum Teil auf
menschenverachtende Art und Weise
erzählt hat bisher nicht hat realisieren
können aber sie würden schon sagen dass
da Erfolge waren von Seiten der
wagnertruppe weil das auch eine Frage
ist immer wieder an uns hier im Chat
herangetragen wird haben die denn
überhaupt so eine Rolle gespielt
tatsächlich für Russland wie würden sie
das beantworten
also ich sehe das so dass wolle da nicht
in die Hände der Russen gefallen wäre
wenn die Gruppe Wagner nicht gewesen
wäre und die Gruppe Wagner ist auch
jetzt in bachmut der hauptgefechtträger
da gibt es überhaupt keine Zweifel dran
verstehe so dann vielleicht noch mal
jetzt haben wir überwachen und länger
gesprochen noch mal allgemein wir waren
vorhin schon beim Thema gegen Offensive
der Ukrainer und wie die und wo die zu
erwarten sein könnte reden wir
vielleicht noch mal über Russland in
diesem Zusammenhang denn wie würde denn
Russland auf eine ukrainische Offensive
reagieren bleibt Putins Truppen nur die
Möglichkeit mögliche Vorstöße abzuwehren
oder sehen sie eher die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Russland
seinerseits noch mal irgendwie proaktiv
sozusagen wird
also wir müssen uns zur Beantwortung
dieser Frage die lange Front angucken
die ja unten vom denn jepper im Süden
bis rauf nach reicht und wo
strategischer Vorteil die Ukraine die
innere Linie besetzt und damit auch
Truppen schneller verschieben kann als
es die Russen auf ihrer Seite auf der
äußeren Linie können das ist einmal ein
ganz wesentlicher Punkt
ich gehe davon aus dass die Ukraine mit
sehr sorgfältige Aufklärung festgestellt
hat wo mögliche Schwächen der russischen
Seite liegen und ich denke dass sie
aufgrund dessen was sie im letzten Jahr
gezeigt haben auch versuchen werden an
den Schwachstellen der Russen
anzugreifen wenn das so ist dann
bedeutet das dass die Russen aus anderen
Bereichen Truppen abziehen müssen oder
Truppen aus Russland nachfühlen müssen
um dann dort diese Bereiche entsprechend
wieder zu verstärken und dann
tatsächlich einen ich sag das mal gegen
Gewicht zu der gegen Offensive der
Ukraine bilden können wobei ich beides
nicht überschätzen würde dafür fehlt der
Ukraine hinreichend Material und auch
zum Teil Munition wir haben ja die
Diskussion über munitionslieferung bis
in die Europäische Union hinein und wie
man die Ukraine besser unterstützen kann
von daher die Ukraine schöpft dort auch
nicht aus dem Vollen weder bei Personal
noch bei Material noch bei
Kampffahrzeugen und Munition von daher
muss die Ukraine mit ihren Kräften sehr
sorgfältig umgehen und muss sehr
sorgfältig darauf achten wo sie die
Angriffe ansetzt damit Sie auch
tatsächlich die Schwachstellen der
Russen treffen wir kommen langsam zum
Ende haben aber noch mal eine Nachfrage
bezüglich der Krim von Ismael 04 Herr
General der ehemalige Oberbefehlshaber
der US-Armee in Europa ben hat es sagt
dass die Ukraine die Krim bis zum Sommer
befreien könnte wie sehen Sie das
also ich kenne Ben Hodges sehr gut ich
weiß nicht ob er sich neuerdingste
Glaskugel gekauft hat ich bin mit
solchen Vorhersagen ausgesprochen
vorsichtig ich habe bei einer Sendung
von ihnen vor ich sag mal einem guten
Dreivierteljahr mal gesagt ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir den 24 August den
Nationalfeiertag der Ukraine unter
anderem Vorbedingungen dann feiern
können und begehen können ich bin
vorsichtig ich möchte da keine
Zeitlinien nennen egal ob wir über den
Angriff der von chakiff aus nach Osten
und Südosten vorgetragen worden ist oder
den Angriff der auf Person oder in
Person geführt worden ist in der Oblast
und für die nehmen das hat alles seine
Zeit gekostet von daher sollten wir mit
solchen Prognosen oder solchen
Vorhersagen vorsichtig sein um auch um
bei unseren zuhören und Zuschauen keinen
falschen Eindruck zu erwecken auf der
anderen Seite muss ich benotisches recht
geben es wäre gut wenn du keine gute
Fortschritte machen würde weil ich
befürchte das auch bei uns in Europa bei
den westlichen Staaten irgendwann die
Geduld was diesen Krieg angeht ger
werden wird und das ist das schlechteste
was passieren kann denn die Ukraine
braucht unsere Unterstützung dann nehmen
wir das als Schlusswort der ehemalige
Nato-General Egon Rams war das von uns
für uns ganz herzlichen Dank für das
Gespräch Herr Rams und Ihnen einen
schönen Abend danke sehr ja und auch an
euch natürlich wie immer vielen Dank
fürs Mitmachen hier bei uns auch euch
einen schönen Abend und hoffentlich auch
ein erholsames Wochenende bis demnächst
demnächst macht's gut ciao